and with just four days until christmas
coped 19 testing sites are experiencing
just a surge in appointments we saw
those long lines across the country yeah
clinics are reporting a mix of travelers
and those that are concerned about the
new variant kate houston stopped by ic
labs in henderson to see how they're
handling the rush
i just want to be saved a steady flow of
cars are filling up the appointment
slots outside of icy labs i have a
young daughter
wife
i want to make sure i if i get infected
i want to make sure i don't give it to
them
or anyone else ivanko thomas is one of
nearly 300 people getting tested tuesday
saying he wants to keep his family
healthy this holiday season that's
important to everyone be safe i got
vaccinated twice i got boosted i'm not
worried about i'm very healthy person
but i want to keep it that way i see
labs is not only seeing an increase in
appointments but positive cases going
from two to three cases a day to 20 on
monday it's starting to spread people
are getting concerned people are
traveling so they want to make
sure they're safe to travel dr isaac
farrell says they're offering rapid
tests which is good for those who are
days away from travel or experiencing
symptoms we're starting to see a big
increase again i expect with this new
variant
we'll probably be close to 20 percent
positive rate but the good news is
especially amongst the vaccinated that
the symptoms are mild kate houston live
local now emphasizing again symptoms
mild fortunately with the new variant
hearing there from medical professionals
the southern nevada health district has
hundreds of open appointments at
community sites availability at cvs and
walgreens varies between locations cbs
says there's been a surge in demand for
their at-home testing kits and there's a
limit of six tests per purchase